The following content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR NELSON: Over the last
couple lectures through
our consideration of a number of
somewhat difficult topics,
including these Carnot cycles
and specific Carnot engine to
represent them, we've tried to
define and understand a little
bit about this very special
function, this entropy.
Where we've got our dS.
It's dq reversible over T. And
our treatment of reversible
and irreversible cyclic
processes, what we saw is that
if we go around a cycle and look
at dq reversible over T,
then this is zero.
Now go all the way around a
cycle, of course, this is just
delta S for the cycle.
And that's consistent
with the idea that
entropy is a state functions.
So if we go around cycle the
cycle, we have the same ending
point, the starting point, same
state, then the change in
the state function
has to be zero.
But we saw that for an
irreversible path around a
cycle, then we have
that, this gives
something less than zero.
And so that was expressed in
Clausius inequality that
includes both these cases.
And now I just want to go
through a number of
calculations of entropy.
How entropy changes for a number
processes, both to just
learn more about it in general
terms and also just to see how
it's calculated and what sort
of changes in undergoes for
different sorts of
changes in state.
So the first very general
example that I want to show is
the following.
Let's say we've got an isolated
system, and it
undergoes some irreversible
change.
So we'll start at one, and we'll
go irreversibly to some
new state, two.
OK, now we can always return the
system back to the initial
state reversibly.
If we do that, then we can't
keep the system isolated.
So it won't be isolated
anymore.
In other words, in order to
arrange things so that you
could have a return
along a reversible
path, it can't be isolated.
In some sense you know that,
because when it was isolated
it spontaneously irreversibly
went from one to two.
And example would be ice melting
at some temperature
that might be higher than
the freezing point.
So you've got solid ice, but the
temperature is above zero
degrees Celsius, so irreversibly
it'll melt.
Systems isolated, it'll melt.
Then you could put the system
in contact with a cold
reservoir reversibly re-freeze
the water to form ice again.
But of course to do that you
couldn't keep it isolated.
You need to have it in contact
with a low temperature bath.
But again, this is
just completely
general at this point.
It's some irreversible process
returned then along a
reversible path.
So let's just look
at what happens.
So here's our path B.
Along path A, well
it's an isolated system.
So the heat exchanged is zero.
And then, for the cycle based
on the Clausius inequality
expressed here, the integral
around the cycle of dq over T
in general, it's less than
or equal to zero.
If there was an irreversible
process involved, then in
fact, it'll be less than zero.
I'll write it here in the more
general case, but we know what
it's really going to be with
the irreversible step.
Well, so we can write this
as the integral of dq
irreversible over T, going from
state one to state two.
Oh, let me rewrite
this down here.
So around the cycle, dq over
T, it's integral from state
one to two of dq irreversible
over T, plus the integral from
two back to one of dq reversible
over T. And of
course, we know that that's less
than or equal to zero.
But this, we know is zero,
right, because this
irreversible step is
taken in isolation.
The system is isolated.
We've already seen that there's
no heat crossing the
boundary of the system.
So we just have this.
So of course this dq reversible
over T from two to
one, that's, what now we've a
reversible path, so that's
just the entropy at the delta
S going from two to one.
It's S1 minus S2 it's delta S,
we can write it as delta S
backwards, right, we're
going back along
that reversible path.
Which is of course negative
delta S forward.
Because around the whole cycle
delta s has to be zero.
So what that says is delta S
forward is greater than or
equal to zero.
That's interesting.
What that's saying is --
remember, we didn't specify
the process.
It's just for any completely
general irreversible process.
For any such process, for any
spontaneous process, this is
going to be the case.
So in other words, for an
isolated system, delta S tells
us the direction of spontaneous
change.
In particular, for the isolated
system, delta S is
greater than zero for something
that's irreversible.
Delta S equals zero for
something that's reversible,
and delta S is never
less than zero.
In a sense, this is a direct
consequence of the Clausius
inequality.
That's a pretty useful result.
So remember when we started this
whole discussion, I tried
to emphasize that the first law
of thermodynamics told us
about conservation of energy.
But it didn't tell us which
way something would go
spontaneously if you just left
the system to its own devices
under certain conditions.
This is telling us that.
We can tell which way the system
will evolve in which
direction it'll go.
This is for an isolated system
and we'll generalize this in
subsequent lectures.
Now, let's look at what
happens if the
system isn't isolated.
So now let's go from one
to two not isolated.
So of course, delta S I'm
going to specify for the
system for reasons that'll soon
be obvious is S2 for the
system minus S1 for
the system.
Of course it doesn't depend on
the path, even though to
calculate it, we need to
find a reversible path.
Just to add emphasis to what we
just did here, of course,
it was the same thing.
In order to calculate delta S
along that irreversible path
for that irreversible process
we needed to construct some
reversible path.
And what we did is imagined
the reversible path going
backwards and then said, OK,
fine then delta S for the
irreversible process must be the
opposite of delta S that
we calculated along the
reversible bath going backwards.
The point is that to calculate
delta S in either direction,
we needed to construct
some reversible path.
All right, and of course
it'll be the same here.
Now, in this case since the
system isn't isolated, that
means heat's going to flow
across the boundary.
So that means heat is going
between, it's being exchanged
between the system and
the surroundings.
So what's happening to
the surroundings?
Generally, we've worry a lot
about the system, but not much
in recent discussions about
the surroundings.
But delta S surroundings
must be something.
We could calculate it.
And that's depends
on the path.
Not because it isn't the state
function in the surroundings,
of course it is, but because
depending on the path, the
final state of the
surroundings will be different.
After all, depending on how much
heat got exchanged, the
surroundings got more or
less of that heat.
Work might have been done
on the surroundings.
So the surroundings are going
to respond, are going to
change also, when the system
changes in this way and it's
not isolated.
And how the surroundings change
will depend on what
path was taken.
And you've seen that before
in calculating things like
pressure, volume, work along
different paths.
Where you calculated delta u for
the system and saw that it
was the same for different paths
but q and w were not the
same for the system, and
therefore, of course, not for
the surroundings either.
So let's just consider
an irreversible path.
And in order to think about
what happens to the
surroundings, let's take the
entire universe which consists
of the system and the
surroundings -- that is a big
isolated system, because
it's everything.
So it's not somehow in contact
with another additional body
or universe.
We can treat the
entire universe
as an isolated system.
So, we're going to think about
the entire universe.
We can think about it as
an isolated system.
Great.
And we know that delta S for
an isolated system, for a
spontaneous process, is
greater than zero.
That's right there.
So delta S for the universe
which is delta S for the
system plus delta S for the
surroundings, and I'll specify
since we're considering an
irreversible process, specify
that, it's greater than zero.
The whole thing happened
spontaneously, and the whole
universe is an isolated
system.
So if we wanted to, we can
write that delta S
irreversible for the
surroundings must be bigger
than minus delta S for the
system in order that there sum
be positive.
All right?
Now, if we consider a reversible
process, then of
course we already know what
happens for an isolated system
in a reversible process,
delta S is zero.
So delta S in this case of the
whole universe, which is delta
S for the system plus delta S
for the surroundings in the
reversible case must
be equal to zero.
In other words, delta S of the
surroundings in the reversible
case is exactly the opposite
of delta S of the system.
Delta S of the system is the
same in either case because
reversible or irreversible,
we're specifying the system,
goes between the same states,
but what happens to the
surroundings is different
in the two cases.
So one way of recasting this
statement or the Clausius
inequality is the entropy
of the whole
universe never decreases.
Of course, in some sense,
that's obvious from this
statement, since we're
considering the universe an
isolated system.
So the entropy in any process
can, it can, the change in
entropy can either be zero or
positive and never negative.
So entropy off the whole
universe never decreases.
That's actually a really quite
profound conclusion.
All sorts of philosophical and
other consequences of it that
are sometimes considered in
things like evolutionary
biology and other things.
And how things can change
altogether an
entire system of things.
Now, I'd like to just go through
a few calculations of
delta S for common processes.
We've seen a few general
features of entropy.
Let's calculate it
for a few things.
So calculations of
delta S. And we
know the general procedure.
Whatever the process is, we're
going to need to find
reversible paths, and along a
reversible path then, we'll be
able to calculate it.
One, let's just take two
pieces of material at
different temperatures.
The entire system is going
to be isolated.
And then let's connect them.
Put some material
between them.
So now heat can flow from
one to the other.
And you know what's going to
happen which is if they start
out at unequal temperatures, and
you wait a little while,
eventually they're going
to wind up at the same
temperature.
In other words, you
know the direction
of spontaneous change.
So let's just see what
happens to delta S.
So isolated system, so there's
no work being done.
There's no heat that's
being exchanged.
So delta u is zero.
What's dS?
Well it's just the sum of the
changes in entropy for the two
sub-systems the two
separate pieces.
So it's dq1 over T1 plus dq2
over T2, I think there's a
type in your notes. it's plus
not minus of course.
But in this case, dq1 is just
the opposite of dq2.
Because whatever heat is flowing
into T1, into this
block, is coming out of this
block, or vice versa,
depending on which
one is hotter.
So this is just equal to dq1
times one over T1 minus one
over T2, which is T2 minus
T1 over T1 times T2.
So that's dS, and then we could
integrate it to get the
delta S, but this is sufficient
for what I'd like
to illustrate, which is just
the sign of things.
We know dS must be greater than
zero for the spontaneous
change that's going to occur.
So let's just make sure that
common sense prevails here.
That says if T2 is greater than
T1, right T2 is hotter.
Then dq must be positive, so
this is positive, this is
positive, dS we know
has to be positive.
So, it says T2 is hotter.
This being positive means heat
is flowing in from this one to
this one, from the hotter
to the colder body.
So it looks right.
If T2 is lower than T1, if this
one is colder, then in
order for dS to be positive,
which it has to be, this
better be negative.
In other words, again heat is
going to flow from the hotter
toward the colder, into
the colder body.
So, as promised, the condition
that dS must be greater than
zero, guides us and tells us the
direction that spontaneous
change is going to occur.
We can tell just from this
condition which way things
have to evolve.
All right, let's try another
pretty simple process.
Let's just take a gas in some
volume V and over here is
going to be vacuum of equal
volume, and we're going to
remove the barrier.
You know what's going to happen
spontaneously, right?
The gas is going to fill the
available volume once it
becomes available.
So this, we'll make this a Joule
expansion, and we'll
make it an ideal gas.
So the process is one mole of
gas at our initial volume and
some temperature, and we'll make
this adiabatic, and this
goes to one mole of gas at a new
volume, 2V and at the same
temperature.
All right, so there's
no work done.
It's adiabatic.
There's no heat exchanged.
Delta u is zero.
Everything's zero.
Almost everything is zero.
What isn't zero?
STUDENT: Entropy.
PROFESSOR NELSON: Entropy.
It's going to tell us which
way this whole thing goes.
So this is an irreversible
process.
In order to calculate delta
S we need to construct a
reversible path along
which this can go.
So here's a way to do it.
We could compress it back,
isothermally and reversibly.
Just like the example I gave,
the general example, where I
mentioned the ice melting.
In that case, it won't
be adiabatic.
We'd have to put it in
contact with a heat
source of some sort.
So reversible process.
We could compress it back to
volume V, isothermally, and
reversibly.
Let me say, there's no -- we
wouldn't have to consider this
process in reverse.
Of course, we could also
consider the forward process
in the presence of some heat
source with isn't isolated and
do this, but let's just consider
the compression.
So, OK, now we'll have
the -- well, once
again, delta u is zero.
It's an ideal gas.
There's no temperature change.
But this time q and w aren't
going to be zero.
They're going to be some
finite numbers that are
opposites of each other.
Because we're no longer
isolated.
So let's just write out delta
S to go backward is dq
reversible over T, and
that's minus dw
over T, not zero anymore.
And where we're going is from
2V to V, we're compressing,
and it's an ideal gas.
So this is the same as p dV, but
it's p dV over T which is
the same thing as going from
2V to V. Now we're going to
replace this with RT over V,
and the T's will cancel.
So it's R dV over V going from
2V to one V. So it's just R
times the log of 1/2.
So now we've just calculated
the value of delta S by
constructing this
reversible path.
Now this is delta S backward.
To do the compression, so of
course delta S forward is just
the opposite of that.
So, delta S forward
is R log 2.
Reassuringly, that's
a positive number.
So this process that we
considered originally, this
irreversibly process in this
isolated system, remember, for
the irreversible expansion
we considered the system
isolated, Happened
spontaneously, and of course
you know that's the case.
Now, I'll just mention, and
later on we'll go into this in
considerably more detail, but
I'll just mention at this
stage through a little bit of
sort of foreshadowing that
everything we've discussed so
far about entropy is with a
macroscopic picture.
We started with heat engines
and Carnot cycles and
macroscopic processes,
reversible and irreversible
processes and so on.
But there's a, and that's
certainly the way it was all
formulated originally.
Part of the power of
thermodynamics is that it
doesn't depend on a specific
microscopic model of matter.
That said though, we
have a pretty good
microscopic model of matter.
We know about atoms and
molecules, and in fact there
is an entirely microscopic
formulation of entropy that
has to do with disorder and
the number of available
states, microscopic states
available to a system.
So I'll just state what
we'll see in much more
detail later on.
Which is in microscopic terms,
it's going to turn out that
the entropy of a system can be
given by R over Avogadro's
number times the log of the
number of distinct microscopic
states that are available
to a system.
Right so in this isolated
system, when we double that
volume, each molecule suddenly
has twice as many states
available to it.
You could formulate that
in a lot of ways.
You can sort of divide up the
volume into tiny little
molecule-sized cubes and realize
well, now, there are
twice as many of them.
Now if I have one molecule, the
number of states doubles.
If I have n molecules, the
number of states goes
up by 2 to the n.
Because for each one of the
molecules, I can select any
one of those states, and
then the next one I
can select any one.
So you have this enormous
increase in
the number of states.
So delta S in this case looks
like R over NA log of 2 to the
power NA, it's Avogadro's
number,
for a mole of molecules.
This can come out
and cancel this.
There's our R log 2 result.
But the point I'm making here
is that could actually be
derived from entirely
microscopic consideration.
We haven't gone through
that yet.
We've done entirely macroscopic
thermodynamics so
far, but we'll do a little bit
of treatment of statistical
mechanics, is what is called
the whole microscopic
formulation of entropy
in thermodynamics.
And that's a really important
fundamental result.
And we'll get to it in much
more detail in a while.
But for now, I just want to
continue calculating entropy
changes for a few more
kinds of processes.
So, how about if we have two
different substances and we
mix them, entropy of mixing.
So, we start with some number
of moles of substance A in
some volume VA, and some other
number of moles of substance B
in volume VB, separated.
And then we remove the barrier,
of course we know
they're going to mix.
So we'll have some total number
of moles, nA plus nB,
and they'll be filling some
total volume, which is the sum
of the two original volumes.
Certainly this is what
we expect to happen
spontaneously.
So are process is nA moles of A,
gas, initial volume VA and
T, plus nB of substance B, I
think this is miswritten as A
there in your notes.
Gas VB and T goes to nA moles of
A plus nB moles of B. Gas,
total volume and T. And
we'll have constant
temperature and pressure.
Well, there was no
p v worked done.
The temperature didn't change
and it's ideal gases, so delta
u is zero, but what
about delta S?
Well again, to calculate
it, we need to find
a reversible path.
This is irreversible if we just
remove the barrier and
let it all go.
But we could at least imagine
a reversible path, and we
could actually construct this
for the right substances.
We could imagine that we can
find some sort of piston here.
And we're going to prepare
to push it inward, with a
membrane that's permeable
only to b.
And over here we could set up
the exact same thing, but this
one's permeable only to a.
And then we could just push them
to recover this state.
And we can do it reversibly.
So we could construct a
reversible process that does
the reverse of this.
And in this case, it'll be
isothermal still, constant
pressure, reversible compression
of the two gases.
So, reversible compression
and demixing.
All right, so what happens?
Well, of course, our delta S
of demixing is going to be
minus delta S of mixing.
Delta u of demixing
is still zero.
Temperature didn't change, ideal
gases, and there's some
reversible work and heat.
So dw in this reversible case,
is just minus pA dVA minus pB
dVB, the infinitesimal amount
of work done as these things
are gradually moved
toward each other.
So delta S for demixing, of
course it's dq reversible over
T, but just like we did right
there, of course, in this case
that's just negative dw.
So it's integral from V to VA,
right, were compressing.
So for substance a, we're going
to go back to there.
It was occupying the whole
volume, and then it's going to
end up in only part
of the volume, VA.
pA dVA over T. Same thing for
B, going to volume B, pB dVB
over T. And now we can
substitute for pressure,
right? pV is nRT, so it's nA
times R log of VA over V plus
nB of R log of VB over V.
Now, so this is a suitable
answer, but I'm going to make
if a little easier by putting
in terms of mole fractions.
So, mole fractions, of course,
XA is nA over n, and XB is nB
over n and XA is also equal to
VA over V and XB is equal to
VB over V for ideal
gases, right?
The molar volumes
are the same.
We're at the same temperature
and pressure.
So that immediately gives us the
delta X of demixing is nR
times XA log XA plus
XB log XB.
And of course delta S of mixing
is the opposite of
this, minus nR XA log
XA plus XB log XB.
Now XA and XB are
mole fractions.
They are between zero and
one, So their log
rhythms are both negative.
There's a negative sign.
So delta S of mixing
is positive.
That's reassuring.
That tells us as we expect that
the mixing should happen
spontaneously and irreversibly
when we remove the barrier.
Any questions so far about how
we're going about these
calculations of delta S?
OK, let's just do a couple
more examples.
Here's a really straightforward
one.
What if we just heat stuff
up or cool it down.
It happens all the time, but
it's pretty important, right?
So let's just heat or cool
at constant volume.
So, we're going to go from
substance A at T1 and some
volume going to substance
A at T2 at some volume.
We can do this.
Delta S is integral of dq
reversible over T. Going from
T1 to T2, but we know how
to do this, right?
It's the heat that we need.
It's just given by the constant
volume heat capacity
times the change
in temperature.
So this is just T1 to T2, Cv dT
over T. And that is just Cv
times the log of T2 over T1 if
Cv is temperature independent.
That's not always the case.
Usually if it's not too big an
excursion of temperature then
it's a reasonable
approximation.
So that's straightforward.
By the way, notice that delta
S is greater than zero if T2
is greater than T1.
In other words, if we heated
it up, delta S is positive.
Notice also delta S is
less than zero if T2
is less than T1.
Delta S is negative
if we cooled it.
Now, under certain conditions
we've seen that delta S can't
be negative.
Why can it be negative here?
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR NELSON:
Yes, I heard it.
It's because the system
isn't isolated, right.
It was for the isolated system
that delta S is always greater
than or equal to zero.
And you know, for the whole
universe entropy never
decreases and so on.
In this case, though, you know
we're taking a system and
we're putting it in contact
with a cold bath
and cooling it down.
It's certainly not isolated.
Heat is being exchanged.
It's going from the system to
the surroundings, to the bath.
So it's fine.
Delta S can be negative.
What would happen if we
calculated delta S of a new
entire system consisting
of the original system
plus the heat bath?
What would delta S be then?
We already kind of did that with
those two blocks, T1 and
T2 in an isolated systems.
What do you think is
going to happen?
In other words, if we call our
system the stuff that is put
in contact with the heat bath,
well OK, then we've seen delta
S can be plus, can be positive
or negative.
Now let's call our system the
original system plus the heat
bath, and we'll put them all in
some isolating box, that's
thermally isolating and so on.
And now we'll put our original
system, which is now sort of a
sub, part of the system, and
it's now going to be in
contact with the cold bath.
The bath that it's in contact
with is colder than it is.
That's why its delta S
is less than zero.
But what's delta S to be for
the entire new system
including the cold bath?
STUDENT: Wouldn't it
greater than zero?
PROFESSOR NELSON: Yes, it's
going to be positive, because
it's an isolated system
and something happened
spontaneously in it, namely the
original system got cooler
and presumably the heat
bath got at least
a little bit warmer.
And it happened spontaneously,
which immediately means delta
S had to be positive for that
entire assembly, of you know
the original system
plus the bath.
Here's another important
sort of process.
Reversible phase change, we'll
melt something or freeze it.
How about water -- liquid
100 degrees Celsius
one bar goes to water.
Gas 100 degrees Celsius
one bar.
Well in that case, you know
what the heat is.
It's just the delta H of
vaporization, right, at
constant pressure.
So there's nothing really
much to calculate here.
Delta S of vaporization for H2O
at 100 degrees Celsius is
just q of vaporization over the
boiling temperature, which
is delta H of vaporization over
the boiling temperature.
So that was easy.
One last thing.
What if we want to calculate the
entropy of melting or some
phase transition not
at equilibrium?
In this case it's at equilibrium
because it's water
and water vapor at 100 degrees
Celsius and one
atmosphere or one bar.
So it's at its boiling point.
But what if it isn't at
its boiling point?
So what if instead, let's take
H2O, liquid, at minus ten
degrees Celsius and one
bar so it's cold.
It's going to freeze.
So it's going to turn into
solid water at minus 10
degrees Celsius and one bar,
we're going to have it be
isothermal.
Now you know that's going to
happen spontaneously, and it's
irreversible.
Irreversible, which means we
can't just straight away
calculate delta S along
this path because it's
irreversible.
But what we can do, just like
we've done before for making
cycles, we can make some other
set of events that are all
reversible.
We can construct a reversible
pass that will get there.
How do we do it?
Well you know for the phase
change, for the freezing to be
reversible, it has to happen at
zero degrees Celsius right.
You know that's where
you have reversible,
freezing and melting.
Reversible equilibrium between
liquid and solid water.
So surely that's got to
get involved here.
H2O liquid zero degrees
Celsius, one bar, in
equilibrium with H2O solid at
zero degrees Celsius, one bar.
Whatever reversible path we
construct that's going to go
from liquid to solid water,
somewhere along the set of
steps, that better
be one of them.
So now what we need to do is
go from liquid at minus 10
degrees Celsius and one bar to
liquid at zero degrees Celsius
and one bar.
That's called heating.
We have to heat it.
And here we have to cool it.
And we've already seen all these
three processes, right.
So for the phase change,
it's reversible now.
This is just delta
heat of fusion.
Great.
Because this is now
reversible.
This is going to
be reversible.
This is going to be reversible.
Great.
So dq reversible, it's going
to be the heat capacity at
constant pressure, the example
we did before it was constant
volume for the liquid dT.
Here, dq reversible is going
to be Cp solid, dT.
Those won't be the same right?
It's one thing to say the heat
capacity of something doesn't
change over some small excursion
in temperature, but
it's another thing when the
thing actually changes phase.
The heat capacity of the
solid and the liquid
won't be the same.
So this we can just finish up in
a jiffy, because we're just
going to add the three things.
So delta S is delta S of
heating, minus, I think
there's a plus that should be
a minus there, minus delta S
of fusion because it's going in
the direction of freezing
the way we've written it.
Plus delta S of cooling.
So integral from T1 to the
melting point of Cp of the
liquid dT over T, minus delta
H of fusion over the melting
temperature.
Plus the integral going from the
heat of the temperature of
melting to T1 of Cp of
the solid dT over T.
That's it, all right?
So delta S is minus delta H of
fusion over T. That's what it
would be for just the reversible
phase change
happening at zero
degrees Celsius.
And then there's this additional
part which is, we
can write it from T1 to melting
point of Cp of the
liquid, minus Cp of the
solid, dT over T.
Now usually we can assume that
these will be temperature
independent in their
own phases.
So we can usually write this
as minus delta H of fusion
over the melting temperature
plus Cp of the liquid minus Cp
of the solid log of T
of fusion over T1.
Any questions?
What did we do?
We constructed a reversible path
going from here to here
and calculated delta S that way,
and of course that has to
be the same as delta S in the
one irreversible step.
All right, more on entropy and
its consequences for how to
figure out what happened
spontaneously next time.